m
bonjour et bienvenue à tous et par le
manque d'eau toute l'actualité politique
et parlementaire avec nomura qui dit
bonjour aux deux jours mickaël et
bonjour à tous et au sommaire cette
semaine la fin de dix ans de traque
oussama ben laden l'ennemi public numéro
1 fondateur d'al qaïda a été tué par un
commando américain au pakistan
son corps a été immergé en haute mer
pour éviter un lieu de pèlerinage ben
laden est mort mais ce n'est pas la fin
du terrorisme a affirmé le président
américain qui confirme qu'aucune photo
du corps ne seront dévoilés lors du
bilan pour le gouvernement fillon 4 ans
après l'élection nicolas sarkozy le
premier ministre tenait un séminaire
gouvernemental pour promouvoir son
action et celle du président en face les
français peu convaincue qui en très
grande majorité jugent mauvais le bilan
de la présidence sarkozy
et pendant ce temps dans le parti
socialiste se prépare aux primaires des
rumeurs annoncent que martine aubry ne
serait pas candidat à la première
secrétaire des manques les amis de dsk
peut s'active une multiplie les réunions
et attendent un signe de leur vie leur
est avec nous pour commenter l'actualité
jean marie bockel bonjour merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau vous êtes
sénateur du haut rhin
vous êtes aussi président d'un mouvement
vous avez créé en 2007 la gauche moderne
tellement moderne qu'elle se situe au
centre et que vous avez participé au
gouvernement fillon l'a été on pourrait
dire qu'une des prises de guerre de
nicolas sarkozy a lors de son arrivée au
pouvoir
et encore socialiste vous avions en
effet accepté en juin 2007 d'entrer dans
le gouvernement fillon
vous aviez sucessivement été secrétaire
d'état à la coopération à la défense à
la justice avant d'être évincé en
novembre 2010 est aujourd'hui votre
coeur balance plutôt pour jean louis
borloo c'est toujours le cas je suis
très clairement engagé avec jean loup
jean louis borloo au sein de cette
confédération de cette alliance
pas seulement descendent d'ailleurs
parce que moi en tant que président de
la gauche moderne d'ailleurs eu un long
parcours au parti socialiste je
considère que je suis avec d'autres à
l'ailé gauche de la majorité c'est pour
ça que j'ai créé la gauche moderne mais
avec les centristes du nouveau centre
avec le parti radical et les autres
composantes
nous avons des choses à nous dire nous
avons la volonté d'être candidat pour
souley il ya d'abord la démarche
politique dans laquelle nous sommes
engagés nous serons samedi au congrès du
nouveau centre le week-end prochain à
celui du parti radical est puis fin mai
à celui de la gauche moderne donc nous
allons porter sur les fonts baptismaux
7,7 fédération cette nouvelle force
politique un cas vocation à équilibrer
la majorité pas simplement dans la
critique
nous nous assumons le bilan nous
assumons un certain nombre de
réalisations parlais tout à l'heure du
séminaire au bout de quatre ans mais
nous serons également dans la
proposition et puis ensuite bien sûr il
ya une démarche qui a vocation à porter
avec la dynamique que nous espèrons
enclencher une candidature aux
présidentielles
et c'est vrai que jean louis borloo est
naturellement le candidat de cette
démarche
ce sera des étapes à venir à chaque jour
suffit sa peine
vous venez d'être invité à l'elysée ça
vendredi m'attendre du matin ça a été à
l'ailier convoqué vu nicolas sarkozy
n'ait pas été convoqué j'ai eu un
entretien avec le président de la
république en tant que chef d'une
formation politique de la majorité ça
n'est pas anormal et dissuader de
soutenir une candidature borloo mais pas
dire oui je suppose mais j'étais jeune
je ne vais évidemment pas vous raconter
un entretien en tête à tête mais j'ai
senti un président évidemment très
déterminé ça c'est clair et les mets moi
d'ailleurs dans les très déterminés à
des freelances à la politique et à
envisager une candidature mais c'est
également l'esprit des petits déjeuners
de la majorité auquel j'assiste
régulièrement avec d'ailleurs d'autres
personnes qui sont dans cette alliance
des centres là j'étais seul et bien sûr
que c'est quelqu'un qui veut convaincre
c'est quelqu'un qui respecte ma démarche
moi je il connaît ma démarche il sait
quel était mon parcours politique
il sait aussi que je ne renie pas ce que
nous avons fait ensemble que j'ai
toujours gardé mon esprit critique et
j'ai quelque sorte mon identité d'homme
de gauche donc je n'ai pas été dissuadés
d'être dans cette démarche mais par
contre la compétition pour l'élection
présidentielle
on sent qu'elle est engagée et ça c'est
une autre histoire c'était plutôt pour
vous séduire que pour vous dissuader
d'aller voir jean louis borloo
écoutez on a eu une discussion franche
ou à la fois il dit ce qu'il a à dire et
il n'y va pas par quatre chemins mais il
écoute aussi ce que vous lui dites déjà
un président candidat
il m'a donné le sentiment data président
potentiellement candidat oui donc
du coup la discussion était extrêmement
franc je crois que il est très sensible
au fait qu' on ne renie pas ce qu'on a
pu faire de bien ensemble après il
accepte la critique parfois
difficilement mais ils l'acceptent et je
pense que ce que nous pouvons faire de
mieux un pour jouer notre rôle au sein
de la majorité
c'est dans cette démarche d'alliance de
confédération c'est être force de
propositions sur les sujets qui
intéressent les français je crois
franchement que c'est l'état d'esprit
dans lequel se trouve aujourd'hui jean
louis borloo que je vois évidemment
c'est pratiquement tous les jours et on
va commenter ensemble l'actualité de la
semaine a bien sûr on commence au lundi
c'est normal avec bien sûr l'annoncé de
la mort du terroriste le plus haï
d'amérique
la nouvelle ka il est français à leur
réveil oussama ben laden a été tué au
pakistan par les forces d'élite
américaines le chef d'al qaïda traqué
depuis le 10 ans était tuée d'une balle
dans la tête la maison blanche bien sûr
et minutieusement préparé la somme est
aussi l'opération de communication
mathilde derrière ce soir je suis en
mesure d'annoncer aux américains et au
monde que les etats-unis ont mené une
opération qui a tué oussama ben laden le
dirigeant d'al-qaïda un terroriste
responsable du meurtre de milliers
d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
innocents
ben laden est mort reste à savoir
aujourd'hui dans quelles circonstances
alors depuis ce matin le site internet
de washington fournit les images de
l'arrestation
sur ces photos barack obama hillary
clinton les visages graves
enfermé dans la situation room la salle
de crise ils suivent la sau en direct
il est presque minuit au pakistan un
commando d'une dizaine d'hommes pénètre
dans son refuge
nom de code de ben laden geronimo 40
minutes de fusillade
trois hommes et une femme sont tués la
radio grésille d'ironie moi qui aie ben
laden est mort
pour y échapper ils auraient même selon
certains utilisent et sa femme en
bouclier humain
plus tard sa dépouille ait jeté à la mer
plus de corps pas de photos non plus le
seul manque certainement dans cette
communication parfaitement maîtrisé
l'absence de preuves
la maison blanche affirme elle pour
l'instant ne pas avoir tranché sur la
diffusion de photos depuis vendredi les
américains allons amorcer aussi avoir
trouvé sur les ordinateurs saisis par
ben laden des projets de préparatifs
d'attentât
ils ont mené une communication parfaite
selon vous les américains
quoi que l'on puisse penser de la
manière dont ça s'est passé ou de la
manière dont ces communiqués avec ici ou
là semble-t-il quelques les hésitations
oralité et les contradictions mais
l'essentiel tout de même ça
personnellement je considère comme très
positif c'est que il y aura peut-être
encore du terrorisme vraisemblablement
vraisemblablement malheureusement mais
il n'ya plus aujourd'hui d'impunité du
terrorisme je dirai au plus haut niveau
des chefs terroristes et ça c'est quand
même une nouvelle intéressante et je
dois dire que si on veut placer cette
nouvelle dans le contexte de l'actualité
par rapport à l'or évidemment je ne
mélange pas à terrorisme dictature
atteintes aux droits de l'homme se sont
ce sont des démarches criminels
différentes mais le fait que dans
l'actualité ça soit par rapport à
certain nombre de comportements qui vont
à l'encontre des peuples et là en
l'occurrence le terrorisme va d'abord à
l'encontre des musulmans et bien qu' il
y ait des attitudes qu'ils soient
stoppés c'est la fin d'une certaine
impunité internationale et ça c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle l'a pas peur
des représailles
c'est une autre question il peut y avoir
des représailles il peut y avoir ici ou
là j'espère que non peut-être des
recrudescences ou la volonté de montrer
qu'on est toujours là
ça c'est possible mais en même temps
comme vous le disiez dans votre
reportage
il ya des choses qui était préparée de
toute façon par contre il ya eu là
encore une fois un coup d'arrêt par
rapport à ce climat d'impunité général
et ça c'est par rapport aux valeurs que
nous pouvons partager universelle avec
tous les peuples et ben c'est plutôt une
bonne chose
les américains reconnaissent aujourd'hui
que oussama ben laden n'était pas armé
lors de l'assaut qui ne s'est pas
défendu il ya peut-être à côté exécution
ce qui vous gêne ou pas encore une fois
j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire là dessus
mais vous savez moi je n'y étais pas il
ya des gens dans ces forces spéciales
nous avons aussi des forces spéciales en
france qui ont pris des risques
considérables content mais je veux dire
écoutez les démocraties vous savez d'un
côté lorsque l'on sait des choses et
qu'on n'agit pas et qu'on laisse ce
comportement criminel avec ses filiales
il faut voir ce que c'est quand même là
nos compatriotes enlevés c'est aqmi
filiale d'al qaïda donc ça il ya aussi
un moment donné dans le respect de nos
valeurs
une capacité ce sont des actes de guerre
d'y répondre et de stopper
après la manière dont se déroule une
opération extrêmement dangereuse avec
des gens qui sont prêts à tout eh ben on
peut s'imaginer que ça se passe pas
tranquillement sereinement
alors là moi je n'étais pas sur place
sans que vous aurez j'exprime également
mon admiration pour ceux qui risquent
leur vie afin que de tels actes ne soit
plus impunis jean marie bockel la mort
d'oussama ben laden a relancé un autre
débat qu'elle est désormais le but de la
présence française en afghanistan
le ministre des affaires étrangères veut
s'accorder le temps de la réflexion
concernant le départ des troupes
françaises
réactions à l'assemblée nationale avec
julia le caureq ben laden est mort mais
les 4000 soldats français présents en
afghanistan depuis 2001 resteront sur
place au moins jusqu'en 2014
trop long pour le parti socialiste qui
réclame une nouvelle fois le retrait des
troupes
nous y sommes allés pour traquer al
qaïda et ben laden notre objectif de
guerre aujourd'hui s'estompe
il fera donc maintenant monsieur le
premier ministre discuter avec nos
alliés mais l'adaptation concertée de
notre dispositif en afghanistan donnant
cette chance à l'espoir de paix pour le
gouvernement pas question de partir
avant d'avoir achevé sa mission sur
place et réussi à rétablir un état de
droit je constate malheureusement que
nous sommes dans une situation d'une
complexité que la position géographique
de l'afghanistan que la situation de ses
voisins
média a rendu presque inextricable à
l'assemblée pourtant certains députés
ump rejoignent l'opposition et demandent
au gouvernement d'avancer le départ des
soldats
aujourd'hui l'objectif est que la
communauté internationale et les forces
internationales se retire à l'été 2014
moi je reste convaincu qu'il faut que le
début du désengagement s'opère plutôt
certains comme jacques myard prône le
retrait total
mais pour se concentrer sur les
nouvelles zones de danger comme le sel
c'est dans le sahel
c'est en méditerranée c'est au proche et
au moyen-orient que nous devons agir
la question afghane est très loin en
réalité des enjeux de sécurité
françaises
la présence des troupes françaises sera
sans doute l'un des débats de la
présidentielle de 2012
depuis dix ans 56 soldats français sont
morts en afghanistan
alors jean marie bockel est ce qu'il
faut retirer les troupes françaises
d'afghanistan avant 2014
le seul désaccord que j'ai dans votre
reportage c'est avec ce que vient de
dire l'excellent jacques myard 7
milliard qu'ils sont désolés que vous
voyez le kiki qui encore une fois qui
réfléchit qui posent des questions mais
la dire qu'il faut aller plutôt là que
là parce que c'est dans ces régions du
sahel que ça se passe c'est à la fois
vrai et en même temps on sait que tout
est lié et au fond si on avait écouté ce
raisonnement on ne serait pas du tout
intéressé à ce qui se passe en
afghanistan
or nous avions là tout de même un
berceau du terrorisme international donc
là je ne suis pas d'accord avec l'avis
qu'il a dit 2004 et pour le reste j'ai
écouté des socialistes poniatowski il
n'y a que des nuances écouter obama
parce qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir a déjà
évoqué ce retrait la programmer et
ensuite on s'adapte à la réalité du
terrain si on a la possibilité sans
mettre en cause ce que nous avons engagé
la organisation de la sécurité avec les
forces de police et des forces
militaires à la fois également la
possibilité qu'il n'y ait pas d'emblée
un effondrement parce que tout de même
on met à juste titre en exergue les
zones qui ne vont pas bien les problèmes
nombreux corruption et le terrorisme de
guerre mais il ya tout de même des
régions d'afghanistan où l'action
internationale a permis des progrès donc
ce qu'il faut c'est que ce retrait soit
1 concertée ne remettent pas en cause
et là qui parce que convenons quand même
que la mort de ben laden ça n'est pas
tout en afghanistan et ensuite on verra
si on peut partir avant tant mieux mais
faisons le de manière concertée sans
remettre en cause des acquis si on ne
peut pas eh bien nous verrons au fond
donc le débat en garde à mais le débat
non j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit que le
débat aujourd'hui en mai 2011 on ne peut
pas encore complètement le trancher ceux
qui se sont exprimés ont exprimé une
méthode et certains ont dit et si on
pouvait aller un peu plus vite pourquoi
pas si on peut aller un peu plus vite
pourquoi pas mais moi si vous voulez en
tant qu'ancien secrétaire d'état à la
défense je me suis rendu sur place je
sais quelle est la difficulté de la
mission et c'est même très bien sûr
c'est pas par plaisir qu'on est là mais
je sais aussi que tous ces soldats qui
vraiment ont souffert ont été blessés
pour beaucoup beaucoup trop sont morts
au fond ils étaient là pour quelque
chose
ces soldats ils sont là pour une conne
il faut que ce retrait ne remettent pas
en cause ce pourquoi on s'est battus ce
pourquoi ils se sont engagés -
jean-marie passion peut partir en 2013
tant mieux si on peut partir plus tôt
tant mieux nous verrons je ne suis pas
paniqué en afghanistan aussi pour
assurer la stabilité du pays là c'est
loin d'être acquis
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai que
il y aurait beaucoup à dire sur le
pouvoir actuel en afghanistan en même
temps il ya des régions où même avec des
pouvoirs locaux en termes de
développement des choses positives se
met en place d'autres où ça s'est
dégradé
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas non plus à
servir de comment dirais-je de béquilles
éternellement
il faut trouver la bonne mesure faut
trouver le bonheur et puis concernant
l'attentât de marrakech les corps des
huit français tués dans le café de la
place jamâa el fna ont été rapatriés en
france cérémonie d'hommage à orly avec
nicolas sarkozy les commandes devant
sissi recueil ne pas partager votre
peine avec vous qui les aimiez tant ses
enfants
cm ses pairs les démocraties ne
laisseront aucun acte de terrorisme
impuni
je ne pensais aujourd'hui pour les
victimes innocentes elles aussi des
attentats du 11 septembre dont les
instigateurs viennent d'être châtiés
comme les assassins de la place jamâa el
fna le seront un jour cela prendra le
temps qu'il faudra des mois des années
peut-être mais ils payeront aussi alors
les auteurs présumés de l'attentât ont
été arrêtés c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
maroc débusquer les terroristes par tous
les moyens un temps c'est très bien que
c'est une nébuleuse al qaïda est une
nébuleuse notamment on le voit nous
france avec la cnhi too soon est loin
d'être gagné oui mais en même temps on
est très engagé y compris par rapport à
aqmi et nous sommes aux côtés des pays
qui sont en première ligne
ces régions subsahariennes que je
connais bien s'agissant du maroc
cette horrible attentat c'est pas le
fruit du hasard vous le savez bien c'est
un pays qui est en train d'évoluer est
en train de continuer à se démocratiser
avec un souverain qui a tout de même
fait des propositions audacieuses y
compris au niveau de la justice sociale
de la démocratie et voilà voilà ce qu'on
essaye de mettre à mal et je pense quand
même regardé au maroc
je pense que la plupart des
des marocains quelle que soit leur
sensibilité politique religieuse plus ou
moins fondamentale plus ou moins libéral
ils se retrouvent
j'allais dire instinctivement et on en a
beaucoup entendu de témoignages sur
l'idée que ça c'est pas possible que ça
c'est pas acceptable et qu' ils ne
peuvent pas rentrer dans ce jeu là ne
peut pas y avoir de solidarité de
porosité de sympathie pour une telle
action au prix qu'on a dit un certain
échec d'al-qaïda des terroristes sur sur
le maghreb alors et un certain échec et
en même temps ne tombant pas non plus
dans la naïveté ou l'angélisme on sait
que que ce soit en tunisie en egypte ou
ailleurs
et je ne parle pas à la situation en
libye où la bataille se poursuit au nom
de valeurs quand même que nous pouvons
partager y compris avec le peuple libyen
mais une fois que la révolution a eu
lieu
la partie n'est pas gagnée pour autant
et il faut vraiment que nous autres
soyons aux côtés de ceux qui avec des
idéaux démocratiques des idéaux
également aux côtés au que des modèles
de modernité de ces sociétés se bat aux
côtés des peuples mais mais mais il ya
de l'espoir
un tout autre sujet à présent mardi mes
amis de dominique strauss kahn se
réunissent un petit peu partout dans
paris
on ne sait pas encore s'il sera candidat
mais en attendant les soutiens de
dominique strauss kahn s'active pas
moins de trois réunions organisées ce
mardi dont une au sénat qui a rassemblé
plus de 70 personnes avec entre autres
des personnalités politiques qui
attendent avec impatience hassine de
washington fabrice qu'une et c'est
devenu une habitude depuis trois ans
pierre moscovici réunit régulièrement
parlementaires et élus locaux autour de
la candidature de dsk
si le rendez vous n'a rien
d'exceptionnel la table s'est agrandie
avec plus de 70 convives aujourd'hui
pour autant pas question de se déclarer
prématurément
je ne vois vraiment pas pourquoi se
précipiter vous savez ces primaires
viennent en réalité assez tôt il ya peu
de grandes démocraties dans lesquelles
la campagne figurent me moi donc du
travail du travail et encore le travail
du rassemblement le seul message
aujourd'hui qu'ils soient un peu
différent d'ordinaire c'est qu'on est de
plus en plus nombreux
cette officialisation de la candidature
de dsk aux primaires socialistes
interviendra le 28 juin selon pierre
moscovici
alors en attendant ses soutiens tente de
préparer le terrain
le projet sert de plateforme pour projet
socialiste
maintenant il ya un programme du
candidat et c'est là-dessus en
échangeant et les remontées de terrain
des uns et les autres et pas simplement
du microcosme parisien
c'est plus clair comme ça au delà de ce
déjeuner deux autres groupes de travail
se sont réunis cette fois à l'assemblée
nationale d initiative qualifiée de
complémentaire et une mobilisation des
strauss kahniens qui ne choque pas les
soutiens des autres candidats aux
primaires
non
je pourrais vite et je vais je suis
invité voilà hasard du calendrier
françois rebsamen et justement invité
dans une autre aile du sénat mais par
françois hollande
pas de doute la campagne pour les
primaires socialistes s'est accélérée et
au même moment circule l'information
selon laquelle martine aubry aurait
renoncé à être candidate aux primaires
s'effaçant devant dominique strauss kahn
un ragot de journalistes répond elle
nous avons dit en juin vous aurez la
réponse en juin et on vous expliquera
arrange pour l'instant tout le reste ce
sont des ragots et je vous le dis
franchement la france va mal pour
nationale augmente
occupez vous de ce quinté à ce français
le pouvoir d'achat et l'emploi et pas
des ragots et des éléments de cannes
viennent d'où ces ragots jean syrien et
j'en ai rien à faire alors jean marie
bockel ou des 34 ans ps derrière vous
vous connaissez bien les arcanes
compliqué de ce parti rpt ago de
journalistes au secret de polichinelle
il y va elle a renoncé
il va pas je les trouvais un peu un peu
stressé dans sa réponse mais j'ai le
sentiment que les divisions ne sont pas
terminées et que ça va leur compliquer
la tâche vous savez moi les leaders de
cette génération que ce soit martine
françois dominique nous étions ensemble
au club témoigne de leur donc je les
connais bien j'ai beaucoup cru en eux
je me souviens de discussions après 2002
avec dominique strauss kahn ou celui
demandé instamment de s'engager dans une
démarche de modernisation la doctrine du
parti socialiste à l'instar de ce qu'ont
fait tous les partis socialistes en
europe et ne l'a pas fait non pas que il
n'avait pas conscience de cette limite
mais peut-être par manque d'audace
pensant que c'était peut-être pas
nécessaire et aujourd'hui ben on
retrouve les mêmes et au fond la journée
mento la mise à plat elle ne s'est pas
fait le projet socialiste mais c'est pas
un projet pour les années à venir quand
martin parr dont dominique strauss kahn
et martine aubry
à partir du moment où en effet on
arrivait à s'arranger entre eux je parle
en général vers la rue oui ça c'est une
autre question mais j'ai vraiment où les
socialistes sont faibles sur le fond
martine aubry a raison de dire que là la
france est confrontée à une crise grave
et qu'on attend des propositions sur
toutes ces questions sinon c'est marine
le pen qui va monter et quand je regarde
le projet socialiste
je trouve que la réponse n'est pas à la
hauteur de l'enjeu si vous voulez donc
là au fond rien n'est joué et ce qui
sera intéressant dans les mois à venir
c'est qu'elles seront les propositions
les projets avant de parler le programme
qui vont enfin réconcilier les français
avec la politique qui vont nous
rapprocher des français s'agissant
maintenant de ces bagarres bon est ce
qu'il ya un deal entre martine et
dominique je n'en sais rien est ce que
françois hollande est en train de
creuser son sillon est ce qu'il ya une
place pour ségolène je suis pas sûr je
suis pas sûr je ressens maintenant de
l'extérieur puisque les socialistes ont
maintenant exclu il ya quelques années
pour cause d'ouverture
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils ne vont pas
épuisé beaucoup d'énergie s'y délecter
d'ailleurs jusqu'à un certain point
et pendant ce temps là il vient à la
majorité dans sa diversité d'être force
de proposition en 2007 vous étiez en
faveur de dominique strauss kahn
oui si jean louis borloo n'y va pas à
l'élection présidentielle est-ce que
vous retournerez riez faire dominique
strauss kahn mais moi je suis clairement
inscrit dans la majorité
je suis fier d'un certain nombre de
réformes que nous avons mené ensemble
je suis critique lorsque les réformes
n'ont pas été suffisamment juste j'ai le
sentiment qu'aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de changements de réorientation
au sein de la majorité sont nécessaires
mais j'ai inscrit ma démarche je suis
cohérent je ne suis pas une girouette au
sein de la majorité parce que je pense
que c'est elle qui peut continuer à
réformer le pays sans drame un sens
diviser les français aujourd'hui je ne
sens pas cette capacité c'est chez les
socialistes et dominique strauss kahn
j'ai toujours la crainte que s'il est
pleinement lumens il ne passe pas le cap
des primaires
et s'il devait en quelque sorte mettre
de côté ses convictions profondes
eh ben
c'est à dire trop centriste tout est
trop non mais c'est qu'on sait c'est que
ces trois idées sociales libérales quoi
je veux dire quand même là la vulgate
enfin les si vous voulez le climat
général au parti socialiste c'est quand
même encore dans les sections dans les
débats avec certains leaders cetc gauche
gauche quoi c on est tous dans la brèche
il pardon là si les candidats de la
gauche tous les tous les leaders disent
qu'ils s'expriment de montebourg hamon
s'il est désigné c'est notre programme
qui mettra en oeuvre quand on voit ce
que c'est que ce programme sera pas on
n'est pas loin on n'est pas loin la
schizophrénie ou du grand écart donc ça
n'est pas gagné tout ça ça n'est pas
facile et je suis pas sûr que le pays
ait besoin de ça aux gens sentent que
vous pourriez encore être strauss
kahniens que vous en disons que vous
sentez dans mon propos de la nostalgie
et des regrets de ce que nous aurions pu
faire
et au fond j'aurais préféré rester dans
un parti socialiste mais les richesses
mais mais mais je n'ai pas de je n'ai
pas de j'ai peut-être des des autres
il a un sentiment d'avoir fait le bon
choix même si ça n'a pas été facile
vous êtes centriste et donc euro/dollar
pas simplement je suis un homme de
gauche je suis alliés avec des
centristes je suis centre gauche c'est
votre affaire
oui elle s'appellera sûrement pas comme
ça parce que c'est réducteur si voulez
moi j'appartiens quand même à la famille
de la gauche européenne j'étais pendant
34 ans au sein du parti socialiste
si j'avais voulu être centriste je
l'aurais été mon père et mon grand-père
l'été j'ai fait un autre choix c'est pas
pour devenir centriste sur le tard par
contre la gauche moderne l'un gauche de
la majorité effectivement à sa place
dans une démarche d'alliance ou ou le
centre gauche puissent se retrouver avec
le centre-droit vous région d'ica oui
bien sûr j'en suis en tout cas je
je suis plus dans cette démarche que
dans une démarche qui serait
effectivement droitière style la droite
populaire où sa libération des centres
est en train de se créer jean louis
borloo et hervé morin jean arthuis hervé
de charette et vous même
l'idée c'est de présenter un candidat
commun pour 2012
l'idée c'est d'abord d'avoir une
organisation commune travailler ensemble
réfléchir ensemble présenter des
candidats aux élections bien sûr mais
sur la base un autre villa mais sur la
base d'un projet il ya une logique de
candidature dans cette démarche il ya
une logique également au sein de la
majorité de diversité de candidature au
stade où nous sommes
après il y aura d'autres étapes nous
vérifierons si notre dynamique rencontre
des français ou pas moi je pense que
toutes les conditions sont réunies pour
que nous ayons une vraie dynamique mais
faisons d'abord le travail et ne soyons
pas non plus et là je rejoins martine
aubry d'une certaine manière
obnubilé sur l'étape finale qui est
celle de la candidature marocaine
ça serait quand même très compliqué de
trouver un candidat unique pour cette
formation écouter hervé morin je suis
complètement dans la course
je n'ai jamais abandonné avec vous qui
pensez ça j'ai jamais eu peur j'ai
toujours considéré que la politique
c'est d'être un engagement c'est pas ça
n'est pas non plus l'isolément pour
répondre c'est un camarade du modem
c'est pas une démarche solitaire et
c'est pour ça que je suis je veux jouer
collectif et que je ne veux pas que nous
soyons dans l'opposition plein à l'autre
entre dans l'eau et jean louis et moi
dogbé querelles d'ego perspective que
ce que veut dire hervé morin c'est qu'il
est candidat au cas où ça a toujours été
sa position ou jean louis borloo ne
l'est pas oui c'est clair
mais si jean louis borloo y va en tout
cas vu de l'extérieur
robin en tout cas c'est pour moi c'est
ainsi que j'ai compris les choses et
j'attends qu'on me dise non non non non
non c'est pas que ça m'arrange vous pas
que ça m'arrange et je n'ai entendu le
dire à plusieurs reprises clairement
donc à moins qu un changement de
position que je ne vois pas d'ailleurs
en regardant cet extrait vous pressé je
vous précise jean louis borloo de se
porter candidat un ami mais reste pas
jean louis borloo jeudi rien ne sert de
courir
pour le moment il faut faire partir
cette confédération il faut faire un
travail de fond
il faut être force de proposition faut
pas simplement tacler son propre camp ça
n'est pas l'état d'esprit jean louis
borloo et ensuite évidemment s'inscrire
dans une démarche présidentielle mais en
respectant les différentes étapes alors
passé la journée de mercredi avec
peut-être un autre prétendant pour 2012
jean pierre chevènement
je serai candidat pour faire bouger les
lignes en ce jeudi matin la déclaration
du président du mrc jean pierre
chevènement a l'air très clair mais un
peu plus tard on apprend qu'en fait il
se décidera vraiment à l'automne
ira-t-il
comme en 2002 où se retire at-il comme
en 2007 l'idée en tout cas est de mettre
un petit coup de pression du côté du psg
buffard c'est une annonce qui a relancé
les craintes à gauche d'un nouveau 21
avril
en 2002 avec un peu plus de 5% des voix
jean pierre chevènement est accusé
d'avoir contribué à l'élimination de
lionel jospin dès le premier tour
hier le sénateur de belfort s'élancer à
nouveau dans la course à l'elysée
officiellement pour contrer la
candidature de dominique strauss kahn le
ministre aux cannes a pris sa décision à
l'heure qu'il est par conséquent
moi personnellement si j'ai un pronostic
à formuler un c'est qu'effectivement il
sera candidat
donc ce ne sera pas un événement à mes
yeux et pour ma part je serai candidat
pour faire bouger les lignes
c'est à dire proposer une conception
économique -
libéral et surtout une autre vision de
l'europe l'ancien ministre plaide pour
une refonte des règles de l'euro une
décision accueilli très fraîchement à
gauche
monsieur chevénement doit apporter au
contraire son talent sa force de son
expérience son prestige à une unité de
la gauche et non pas une division de la
gauche
je vais finir par me demander si
moi-même je vais pas être candidat il
avait fait 5,3 pour cent en 2002 j'avais
fait 5,25 pour cent donc si on considère
que ceux qui ont dépassé la barre des 5
% doivent obligatoirement être candidat
en 2012 c'est à désespérer de la gauche
jean pierre chevènement ira-t-il
jusqu'au bout ou s'agit-il d'un moyen de
pression sur les socialistes
son mouvement est en train de négocier
des accords avec le ps pour les
élections sénatoriales et législatives à
venir et il y à un précédent 2006 jean
pierre chevènement est candidat mais une
fois un accord passé avec le ps il se
range derrière ségolène royal alors vous
connaissez bien la question jean marie
bockel a été sans son porte parole à
jean pierre chevènement avant de claquer
la porte
18 ans voilà est-ce que vous pouvez
qu'il peut encore mieux aux socialistes
moi je trouve surtout que jean-pierre
avec clichés des désaccords anciens mais
aussi quelques accords fort est une voie
originale dans la république française
même quand on n'est pas d'accord avec
lui il vous oblige à qualifier vos
positions à réfléchir que ce soit sur
les questions européennes sur l'euro
encore une fois je suis d'ailleurs très
heureux d'être dans le même groupe que
lui le rds au sénat on se bat donc
régulièrement mon n'a jamais cessé de se
voir s'ils voulaient c'est un peu le
même raisonnement que celui qu'on a fait
tout à l'heure au sein de la majorité si
d'emblée on considère qu' on ne peut
être que dans une stratégie deuxième
tour qui ne peut y avoir que deux ou
trois candidats
si malheureusement le front national
passe et la barbe non ce ne peut y avoir
que trois candidats potentiels pour être
dans les 2 candidats du deuxième tour
pardon si on part dans ce raisonnement
on tue tout débat au fond ma mère il a
raison sur un point 1 c'est que ces
candidatures à 5%
je pense notamment à celle de cheminots
ont apporté quelque chose et jospin
n'ont pas perdu à cause de chevènement
j'en suis convaincu mais maître des
rêves gentil qui lui sont proches mais
très pourrais moi j'ai eu de grands
désaccords avec j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
pour pour jospin sur le plan sur pandora
les messieurs repères de cheminots mais
non je ne le pense pas c'est trop facile
donc jean pierre avait déjà à l'époque
une voie originale il avait des choses à
dire il avait des points de désaccord il
avait des propositions regarder son
bouquin c'est à bouquin extrêmement
intéressant n'est pas obligé d'être
d'accord avec tout et donc ceci a eu une
personne qui est légitime à faire un
tour de piste ensuite on verra sur les
présidentielles c'est bien seulement
après ce qu il ya une dimension tactique
de négociation
ah bah il n'est pas interdit des
tacticiens nous verrons le moment venu
en tout cas tout ce qu'ils désirent dans
la période où il pousse sa candidature
ça ne sera jamais médiocre on a dit au
fond c'est ça quand j'entends tellement
propos politiciens parfois médiocres son
contenu on pourra jamais faire ce
reproche à chevènement mercredi toujours
le sénat aux terres une proposition de
loi des socialiste visant à réprimer la
négation du génocide arménien un texte
examiné dans un climat électrique des
débats passionnés et sous le regard de
charles aznavour pierre baux de joseph
rien n'ya fait pas même l la
mobilisation du plus célèbre d'entre eux
le texte visant à réprimer la négation
du génocide arménien a été rejetée
aujourd'hui au sénat à une large
majorité ont fait l'histoire pour son
propre pays
on ne fait pas l'histoire pour le monde
entier parce qu'autrement des génocides
on va aussi demain dire que les
américains ont éliminé les indiens
pourquoi pas et ce qui se passera demain
on n'aura pas le droit de le dire non
plus c'est une erreur c'est pas une
erreur politique c'est une erreur
humaine reconnue par la france en 2001
le génocide des arméniens par les turcs
a fait plusieurs centaines de milliers
de morts
mais la communauté française arménienne
voulait plus comme pour l'achat
ils demandaient la pénalisation de la
négation dehors c'est l'incrédulité
je trouve que c'est une honte c'est
légalité vis-à-vis des autres génocides
voilà pour qu'on puisse enterrer nos
morts tranquillement à la tribune
bernard henri lévy qui a fait le
déplacement s'emporte contre la haute
assemblée peut-être plus cynique encore
l'insistance avec laquelle a été plaidée
par les orateurs de droite et la gauche
la nécessité de ne pas froisser
contrarier blessés aux habitudes en 2007
nicolas sarkozy en avait fait une
promesse de campagne
ce soir les familles devant le sénat
préviennent qu en 2012 leur vote
sanctionnera le président sortant ont
pour préciser qu'il y aura une autre
proposition de loi déposée à l'assemblée
d'ici la fin du mois de mai jean marie
bockel ce texte qui a été retoquée par
les sénateurs
finalement c'était pour pas se fâcher
avec la turquie non moi je ne vais pas
voter non plus mais comme député j'avais
voté en 2001 et ça avait été controversé
savez fâcher la turquie je vous rappelle
moi même des discussions vives avec
l'ambassadeur etc
j'avais voté le texte sur le génocide
donc je veux dire quand même cet acte
fort il a eu lieu 1
et si la boucle qui si elles étaient au
lit la france a pu payer des
conséquences dans ses relations
commerciales et kanouté la turquie ce
fut le cas donc je veux dire ne disons
pas cela ne nous faisons pas de procès
d'intention première et première
éléments deuxième élément lorsque
certaines personnes dont je comprends
l'émotion
10 il ya des propos négationnistes qui
doivent être sanctionnés il faut savoir
que le garde des sceaux envoyé une
circulaire de rappel à tous les
procureurs et ce à la loi actuelle le
permet tout à fait pour que ces propos
soient sanctionnés donc c'est pas la
peine d'une nouvelle loi et moi je vous
dis l'aube secrétaire d'état à la
défense et aux anciens combattants et
dans l'esprit d'ailleurs aussi du
rapport à quoi y ait un qui avait réuni
des députés toutes sensibilités on a
fait ce travail je crois beaucoup au
travail de maurienne mais je pense
depuis des années et je me suis
d'ailleurs inscrit dans cette démarche
dans mes fonctions gouvernementales
je pense que il faut cesser les lois la
multiplication des lois alors là c'est
pas une loi mémorielle c'est une loi
évidemment qui portera faits extrêmement
graves puisque c'est un génocide
mais encore une fois
il y a l'histoire qui doit être laissé
aux historiens
d'une part et d'autre part il ya la
condamnation du génocide qui l a été
l'honneur de la france
elle l'a fait c'est pas la peine de le
refaire parce que si vous leur faites à
chaque fois sans que de vrais besoins
juridiques de le faire pour condamner
des propos négationnistes vous atténuer
la force tout simplement
mais le symbole c'est fait donc je crois
qu'il me va je ne me retrouve pas dans
les dents les propos de bernard henri
lévy en l'occurrence jean marie bockel
au nom vient au jeudi c'est l'heure du
bilan pour le gouvernement fillon
et oui ça fait quatre ans que nicolas
sarkozy est au pouvoir et pour souffler
les bougies françois fillon invite à
matignon son équipe gouvernementale
l'objectif est de faire bloc derrière
nicolas sarkozy candidat présumé donc
pour 2012 et défendre le bilan charmant
andrieu rien n'est encore officiel mais
c'est le top départ de la campagne et
c'est au tour du premier ministre de
mettre en avant le bilan gouvernemental
ce matin tous les ministres ont répondu
présent à l'appel de françois fillon
la feuille de route est claire il s'agit
de serrer les rangs
malgré le record d'impopularité de
nicolas sarkozy
j'entends les critiques à l'égard du
président je veux dire qu'elles sont
injustes et qu'elles sont souvent très
basses le président de la république que
je connais celui que je côtoie depuis
quatre ans est bien éloigné des
caricatures qui en sont faites
selon le dernier baromètre tns sofres
seuls 20% des personnes interrogées font
désormais confiance au chef de l'état
françois fillon invoquent la crise
économique mondiale reconnaît quelques
bémols
mais le reste malgré tout un bilan
positif nous avons essuyé quelques
échecs qui ont pu décevoir ceux qui
espéraient tant en nous mais personne ne
peut
nous jeter la pierre en disant ils n'ont
pas tenu leurs engagements
le pouvoir d'achat a progressé
naturellement nous aurions souhaité
qu'il progresse plus mais nous avons dû
affronter cette crise économique et
financière et c'est une performance de
la france des français et le
gouvernement et après tout sa part sous
l'autorité du président de la république
d'avoir maintenu une progression du
pouvoir d'achat pour les français en
moyenne dans un contexte aussi difficile
reste que près des trois quarts des
français jugent ce bilan mauvais après
quatre ans de présidence
l'ump mais sur la pédagogie et la
répétition accusé de rester trop en
retrait françois fillon doit désormais
s'exposer dès demain il se rendra à toul
pour vanter une nouvelle fois le bilan
gouvernemental alors des sondages
catastrophiques qui se succèdent 73% 80%
des français qui jugent mauvais le bilan
de nicolas sarkozy ça va être très dur
de de faire de se faire vrp de du bilan
sarkozy dans les semaines qui viennent
je pense qu'il faut que nous sachions
faire la part des choses moi
j'assume le bilan de la période où
j'étais au gouvernement à la fois les
aspects positifs qui sont nombreux
également les erreurs et même des
désaccords que j'ai pu avoir mais qui
n'ont pas empêché de rester donc je ne
crache pas dans la soupe
je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
un bilan en demi teinte avec encore une
fois des aspects positifs non seulement
sur le plan économique et social mais
également la capacité d'avoir tenu bon
pendant la crise terrible que nous avons
traversée en 2008 et à laquelle on
continue à être confrontés à bien des
égards mais est au fond il reste encore
un an pour la majorité
le premier nice parlais à l'instant du
pouvoir d'achat je vous dit aux français
le pouvoir d'achat a progressé mais pas
assez même si certains chiffres disent
que cela exact ce que vivent nos
concitoyens on le voit sur le terrain
dans nos villes c'est le reste à vivre
1 et de ce point de vue là pour beaucoup
ils ne vivent pas du tout ça comme une
progression mais comme une régression
alors que par ailleurs ils ont le
sentiment que les écarts se creusent
entre les très riches je pense que la
question de la prime est une question
importante à laquelle il faut vraiment
qu'on travaille qu'on puisse apporter
des résultats
je pense que sur les questions de
société on est toujours confronté à des
problèmes de sécurité de tension j'aime
on a une mission auprès de denise
l'intérieur sur la prévention de la
délinquance
mais je pense qu on résumera mieux ces
questions en articulant les moyens en
mettant la police sur le terrain plutôt
qu'en ayant des débats très clivant 1 et
qui droitise le débat public
des erreurs ont été commises iv savoir
le reconnaître redresser la barre mais
il ya encore une année pour le faire et
moi encore une fois je le ferai dans
l'esprit de faire gagner la majorité
jean marie bockel d'or c'est aussi
l'intermédiaire de cette ferme
innovation de de participer à ce débat
de démultiplier les propositions et pas
simplement d'être dans la défense et
illustration tenir sur son bilan de
nicolas sarkozy françois fillon a dit et
a parlé de la personnalité
nicolas sarkozy dans un livre hervé
morin où vous allez côtoyer dans cette
confédération est assez dur avec nicolas
sarkozy il parle d'un homme brutal outré
et parfois indécent vous qui étiez dans
ministres de nicolas saada corps avec
cette description romain connu beaucoup
là moi c'est pas mon style de tony
personnes quelle manière je dirais
brutalité parfois oui franchise aussi
outré par ces dits outrés qui est tous
très hervé morin de quoi par l'attitude
d'accord ça comme je veux dire brutalité
oui franchise aussi c'est à dire que au
fond très dans la résine indécent il a
le président de la république il a les
défauts de ses qualités
mais il a aussi les qualités de ses
défauts et au fond s'il doit y avoir une
interpellation à nicolas sarkozy dans la
période qui viennent quelle que soit sa
décision par rapport à la présidentielle
c'est peut-être de canaliser son énergie
je crois d'ailleurs que il en a
conscience même s'il ne faut jamais se
se changer complètement parce que ça ne
marche pas 1 et mettre toute son énergie
au service finalement 2-1 2-2 l'idée qui
l'a amené à cette question d'accord avec
moi je n'ai pas lu le livre d'hervé
morin encore une fois moi mon style à
moi on me le reproche parfois c'est
rarement d'être dans la critique brutale
ou
dans le clivage absolue au niveau des
personnalités et donc je non je refuse
de rentrer dans cette polémique en ce
qui me concerne ça c'est clair on va
tout donner on vient à l'amitié que j'ai
pour 1 démarrera avec lequel j'ai
travaillé mais chacun son style
là aussi dans la manière de l'exprimer
l'écrivain nîmois
quand j'ai des choses à dire au
président notamment dans les petits
déjeuners de la majorité ou quand je le
vois en tête à tête je le lui dis en
face
allez jean marie bockel va terminé
tristement cette émission avec la mort
de patrick roy député socialiste du nord
décédé d'un cancer à l'âge de 53 ans
en février dernier il avait
courageusement fait son retour dans
l'hémicycle avec un discours qui avait
serré la gorge de ses collègues on
écoute j'ai été bouleversé par le
soutien de mes collègues de gauche et du
groupe socialiste je dois dire aussi que
j'ai été autant bouleverser autant
bouleversé par le soutien tout aussi
humaniste du gouvernement de vous
monsieur le président alors que je vous
vilipende à longueur de séances
vous avez été à mes côtés sans faille
mais je vais vous le redire ce des
boullereaux dire je vous aime toutes et
tous
la vie est belle jean marie bockel
je suis très ému c'est ça aussi la
république et les soldats de la
république et ça ne l'avouera partage
j'ai connu il était très engagé sur la
lutte contre la mire antoyé parce que
beaucoup de travailleurs que sa région
du nord on avait souffert et comme
secrétaire d'état à la justice les
dialogues avec lui et dans le dialogue
sur des questions qui lui tenait à coeur
c'était un autre homme que le bretteur
de la séance publique et en même temps
c'était le même homme on signera aussi
le décès de bernard stasi longer
chantre de la laïcité également j'étais
l'ami oui parce que nous étions ensemble
densité unis il s'occupait beaucoup de
coopération décentralisée c'est
quelqu'un qui a contribué avec d'autres
à me construire dans mon idéal politique
nous signalons aussi le dessin d'une
autre députée cette semaine françoise
olivier coupeau qui était député du ps
et qui avait 51 ans c'est la fin de
cette émission merci d'y avoir participé
merci quant à nous fidèle à son projet